we are potentially minutes if not hours
from hearing what is expected to be a
list of 100
pardons from donald trump we don't know
as of this moment whether trump will try
to pardon himself
whether he will issue blanket
pre-emptive pardons for his children or
son-in-law or rudy giuliani at this
moment of recording and this may change
within an hour
or within a couple of hours we don't
have that information
we know trump is expecting to pardon
about a hundred people today
however we have in the background an
insane story
alleging that rudy giuliani donald
trump's lawyer i don't know if he's
still technically his lawyer it's never
been clear
it hasn't been clear for months rudy
giuliani is being accused of
selling pardons by trump for two million
dollars
now the background on this
is that for some time we've heard
rumblings
of those who were collecting consulting
fees
i guess you would call them in order to
lobby
for a pardon from donald trump and now
specifically rudy's name and the cash
figure
of two million dollars is being
associated with this uh
we know that there have been folks for
example who have said
listen um if you give me 50 grand
i'll try to get you a pardon and if i
succeed
you give me another 50 grand a one-time
top advisor
to the trump campaign reportedly
actually collected that 50 grand
in order to try to seek a pardon for a
guy named
john kiriakou who's a former c.i.a
officer convicted of illegally
disclosing classified information
and kiriakou as he says it agreed to the
50 000
upfront fee and a 50 000 performance
bonus so
a 100 grand for a pardon not too bad 50
grand even if it fails okay that's i
guess the risk you're willing to take if
you're paying for pardons
but this is where the story gets very
interesting as reported by the new york
times mr kiriakou
who opted to go with the 50 down 50 if
we get it
uh payment plan was also offered
uh to pay two million dollars to rudy
giuliani
for what was claimed to be an
offer to secure a pardon so sort of like
you know you go to get a car and you can
trade in a car
or not and you can lease or you can
finance and if you lease you could do 24
or 36 months and maybe you want 10
000 miles a year or 12 or 15. there were
pardon
plans available you could choose to do
50 down 50 if we get one
that's one possibility or you could go
with someone presumably believed to be
closer to the president rudy giuliani
who just wanted 2 million flat and i
guess was saying
you can definitely get the pardon this
way although there's never really a
guarantee of anything when donald trump
is involved and of course the immediate
question is could this possibly be legal
and um i hate to to say this but
it's not completely clear in the sense
that
certainly a president selling pardons
would not be legal
that that would be against the law now
whether you could prosecute a president
for it
that is certainly a question mark and
there are many people who say you can
and others who say it would be very
difficult what we're talking about here
can all be couched under legal
representation
and when rudy giuliani was confronted
the so the fbi was alerted rudy's
selling pardons for 2 million
and when rudy giuliani was confronted
about it rudy didn't say that's crazy
i don't know anything about 2 million or
anything like that i haven't talked to
anybody who wants a pardon
rudy giuliani's response was i challenge
the characterization of what it was i
was offering
and that tells you everything you need
to know i
challenge the characterization uh
and and we'll even look at this key part
from the new york times mr kiriakou was
separately told that mr trump's personal
lawyer rudolph giuliani could help him
secure a pardon for two million dollars
but mr kiriakou rejected the offer but
an associate
fearing that mr giuliani was illegally
selling pardons alerted the fbi
mr giuliani challenged this
characterization
that denial is barely a denial you're
challenging
the way it is characterized and what
obviously is going on here is that legal
services are being offered i'm
sure that the way this is being framed
is rudy says
listen i offer legal services which
include
representing your request for a pardon
between the lines it's i talk to trump
every day
and i have influence over him and i feel
really strongly that i can
make sure you get a pardon but what i'm
offering is legal representation i will
write the letter
i will represent you in any back and
forth i will represent the
pr and public facing part of this and i
estimate that my legal fee is going to
be two million dollars
and i take that as a retainer up front
is that illegal no probably not i mean
this is one of those things where by the
letter of the law that's
probably not against the law and so
the move by rudy giuliani of course is i
challenge
the characterization it is insane
that this is what's going on and by the
time you listen to this we may know
who's on the pardon list
we're expected to know at some point
today we will certainly cover it for you
on tomorrow's program
the after the fact will be figuring out
who paid what for the pardons and again
technically it may be who paid for
consulting services
related to how to best ask
for a pardon i don't expect to see
anybody go down for selling pardons
because ultimately the only person who
can really sell the pardon
is trump himself because he's the one
doing the pardoning i don't believe it's
trump who's doing it
it's clearly people around him one of
our sponsors is
four sigmatic the company best known for
their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 5 star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot slash pacman the link is
right underneath this video